[Music]
with the Sochi Winter Olympic Games just
around the corner athletes will be
competing for bronze silver and gold or
will they the winners will actually
receive a gold medal made of almost
entirely sterling silver this first
place medal will be practically
identical to the silver medal except it
must be covered in at least 6 grams of
pure gold
in fact it was in the year 1912 that the
last solid gold medal was handed out the
current bronze medal is made of a metal
alloy composed of mostly copper and tin
potentially valued at only $4 meanwhile
athletes who win first place on February
15th to 2014 will receive cosmic metals
which are gold medals embedded with
fragments of the Super Bowl I'd meteor
which exploded over Chelyabinsk Russia
exactly one year ago but gold medals
weren't always awarded to champions at
the games of the first Olympiad in 1896
winners received a silver medal along
with an olive branch
the runner-up got a bronze medal with
third place finishers receiving nothing
China also received nothing at the
Olympics for a long period of time with
their first Olympic medal coming in 1984
and while the Olympians made trained in
gymnasiums the word gymnasium actually
comes from the Greek word gym nose
meaning naked so it's no surprise that
ancient Greeks competing in the Olympics
were completely nude nudity would be
hard to pull off at the Winter Olympics
though which occurred for the first time
in 1924 in Xiamen Eve France
shortly after this date in 1936 the
Olympics were broadcast on television
for the first time held in Berlin
Germany during the Nazi regime the fuzzy
black-and-white images replaced
conventional radio coverage drawing an
estimated audience of 150,000 viewers
though as the Olympics grows older some
Olympians seemed to be getting younger
the youngest ever Olympic medal winner
was Demetrios laundress who was awarded
a bronze medal in gymnastics at the age
of 10 on the other hand the oldest
Olympic medal winner was Oscar Swan who
won an Olympic silver medal in shooting
at the age of 72
the first snowboarding Olympic event was
held in Nega know in 1998 it was
Canadian Ross Rebecca Lee Adi who
infamously took home the first gold
medal ever in this event in a scandal he
lost his medal the next day because Nana
grams of marijuana were found in his
body claiming the cause was secondhand
smoke at the time Ross is now entering
the medical marijuana business with his
first cannabis cafe
putting in Whistler entitled Ross's gold
mix that gold with the blue red green
and black rings and white background and
you get the Olympic logo representing
the colors of every country's flag in
the world
unlike the two canceled Winter Olympics
during World War two it's a reminder of
our international community's
consistently coming together and because
of all the excitement surrounding the
Olympics we've decided to release a
video every single day starting this
Thursday February 6th for 19 days
straight
can't wait our amazing partners at the
CBC already have five of the videos up
now for you to binge on just head to
cbc.ca slash olympics slash science says
to watch them before anyone else there's
a clickable link in the description
below that's right we'll be looking at
your burning questions like why we get
nervous - sex effect athletic
performance the ideal Olympic diet and
more it's a science blitz but we also
want to know your questions for this
special series use the hashtag the
science says and let us know you're
burning Olympic questions and as always
subscribe for more awesome science
videos